speaking of gross here's Rashida Talib
sir
the Free Speech Warriors today
has expired that our country is failing
you today through this Chambers the
gentleman is no longer recognized well
shut up just like the crocodile tears
another disgusting one to leave they're
just terrible and no one's being
censored Talib can go on every MSNBC
crazy show and say whatever she wants
ilhan Omar can do the same thing they
can say whatever they want in Congress
and bring up whatever bills they want
and expose themselves as the racist
little monsters that they are they can
do all of those things you don't have a
right to be on a committee right if all
they did they removed three people right
so again they removed swallow white guy
they removed Schiff white guy and ilhan
Omar so was this all about race and
bigotry and hating women and everything
else anyway uh you may have seen a whole
bunch of these type of hysterical videos
that were all out on Friday where the
Democrats one at a time more hysterical
than the next and crying and screaming
and genuflecting and just absolute
Ridiculousness this was my favorite one
this was AOC
Ard is
we're doing God's work here guys we
really are
[Music]
foreign